[Music]
hey caitlin
yeah meow and owl just came
with this letter
[Music]
you didn't write anything on it it says
you're accepted to hogwarts wizarding
academy
wow i wonder what house i'm gonna be in
but because of remote learning
the sorting hat is now online
[Laughter]
let's see what house we're in
and this is this is an ode to our
childhood memories
of harry potter no relationship to any
authors who might have gone a little bit
crazy recently
yeah yeah yeah we'll keep we'll keep the
two separate
we've got a lot of requests to take the
harry potter
wizard sorting hat etc quiz
yeah so that's what we're going to be
doing today and we're going to hop
right into it i'm kind of surprised that
neither of us has ever done this before
i know i don't know what i am do you
have any predictions about what you're
going to be
hufflepuff
i feel like i might be a slytherin i
think you might be a slytherin or a
ravenclaw but like
maybe slytherin i don't know slytherin i
don't know
i don't know i'm excited but what's
weird okay so
um for those of you listening we're
gonna try to describe everything for you
for those of you on youtube
you'll be able to see our two screens as
we go through the quiz
and i'm already confused because the
first question is river or forest for me
and moon are stars for me like one what
kind of a question is this
two why are they different yeah one's
weird
maybe because it knows that we are
different you know like we consumed
harry potter books in very different
ways i remember when i told you
that i when i got the books i would kind
of read them in a single day
you were kind of horrified yeah well i i
spread mine out because i wanted it to
last because i'd have to wait a long
time for the next book so i wanted to
spread it out it's kind of like
a little bite of dessert every single
day instead of like
tire cake yeah okay
any other should we talk about any harry
potter memories before we just move on
and take the quiz
um my main memory was being on the news
because uh
my most recent harry potter memory it
was the final movie and my friends and i
went
to the premiere and we all dressed up
like harry potter style
we sat in line for like five hours
um and during that time we ordered a
pizza
we ate so much popcorn so much it was
like the like
like the extra fluorescent yellow with
extra yellow on top
you could see it on camera it was
glowing on camera and i
this must have been a movie theater that
served alcohol because i think we had a
couple beers
we felt so disgusting by the time we got
to the movie
because we were just like so enjoyable
so much popcorn so much pizza
plus beer it was a i mean it was fun
at the beginning and then it was not fun
but yeah but we were on the news
but this is so crazy that the harry
potter franchise spanned such like
a large chunk of our yeah lives or
something the books and the movies
that's a big chunk of it
did you know that harry potter adults is
it
well it's it's i think it's kind of
similar to like disney adults have you
heard of these
it's basically like millennials that
like really love harry potter or like
for disney adults it's mostly
millennials that really love disney
but like one thing that caitlin has
talked about a lot and i totally agree
with her on the harry potter front of
this
they should make a series about a
pre-series a pre-series yes
about like the the the parents
generation like i want to know more
about like
james and lillian snape and like all of
them when they were in school
they kind of they kind of like went into
some of the backstory in the later books
there's so much more there's so much
there yeah i want more
explore that explore that just like we
will be exploring
the the the sorting hat eventually nice
segue
okay so shall we answer our first
question i guess like if i were gonna
choose between river and forest i would
choose forest
if i was gonna choose between moon and
stars
which is even you know yours you can
just be like well which do i want to
hang out anymore
i'm gonna go moon because you can't see
the stars sometimes
sometimes the moon is super bright and
orange so
which of the following do you find most
difficult to deal with
loneliness boredom hunger
or being ignored oh there's more cold
[Laughter]
let me see um
loneliness i haven't been a lonely in a
long time because
we've been married for a while boredom
never bored
boredom yeah it's you can feel it
caitlyn gets a little angry i do get a
little angry when i'm hungry
um
what's your second question what kind of
instrument
most pleases your ears this is so weird
the piano
the drum the violin
the trumpet i mean no not not like
you know no offense to anyone who loves
trumpet but
that's a lot if you're gonna pick
imagine music that's
just that one thing most pleasing in
most scenarios
the piano is the most versatile yeah for
me
okay given the choice would you rather
invent a potion that would guarantee you
glory love
power or wisdom
[Music]
let's see glory love power our wisdom
well i already have love
um would glory be equivalent to like our
youtube channel yeah
i think so i might pick that
just like guaranteed channel health
i don't know i mean like wisdom would be
cool too or would power
be like them followers you know
i don't know i feel like glory is much
more
yeah it i don't know if it feels like
it's like
yay the channel is doing well whereas
power means like maybe
you're more influential like you're a
bigger influencer
or like i don't know you have more
influence i don't know what that is the
channel do well
i don't want to influence like your
choices yeah
and like wisdom could be cool but it's
like you would learn it and then just
i'd apply it
to how to make the channel do well okay
glory
which road temps you most
the twisting leaf strewn path through
the woods
the wide sunny grassy lane the narrow
dark lantern-lit alleyway is that would
that be yours
not necessarily it also seems sketchy
yeah the coupled street
lined with ancient buildings
it would probably be ooh so it's the
twisting leaves soon pass through the
woods or
the wide sunny grassy lane i know which
one i would pick but i don't want to
influence your choices
which road tempts you most road
if it's a road that i just want to walk
down just to walk down it the twisting
leaves to a path
through the woods okay
all right back to you katelyn over every
i mean once every century the flutter by
bush produces flowers
that adapt their scents to attract the
unwary if it lured you
it would smell love okay this is a fancy
way of asking what my favorite smell is
the sea home a crackling log fire
or fresh parchment i'm gonna go with
fire yeah
yeah our home our home you know what's
funny when we leave our house for a
couple days or something on a short trip
and we come back
it smells like wood yeah
smells like wood smells like wood all
right
so which of the following would you hate
people to call you ignorant
selfish ordinary
or cowardly
um ignorant i don't care i don't care i
don't care what people call me
if like if i'm ignorant you know i know
selfish i think that would bother me
ordinary i know how special i am or
cowardly
i think i think selfish that bothered me
the most
i have a really easy question oh we both
got the same question oh nice
if you're attending hogwarts which pet
would you choose to take with you cats
toes or owls
yeah it's obvious cats
oh now we're like on the same thing okay
if you
were attending hogwarts which pet would
you choose to take with you a ginger cat
a white cat a siamese cat a tabby cat
a black cat well obviously yeah jew is
coming with both of us we share her
even if we end up in different houses
now it diverges again okay
uh here you read yours first since i
just did mine or since i just read that
for us
a troll has gone berserk in the
headmaster study at hogwarts
it's about to smash crush and tear
irreplaceable items and treasures in
which order would you rescue
these objects from the trolls club if
you could
a nearly perfect cure for dragon pox
uh what it only shows one it only shows
one
select a position for the cure well in
relation to what yeah what the heck
that's dumb i guess three because
i don't know student records going
back 100 years
i'm a serious handwritten book
full of strange runes oh you can reorder
oh
okay that's that's done not the most
logically what's dragonbox
yeah is it i guess that's higher
student records no
and mysterious handwritten book i think
that's
most important okay interesting
i don't know if i like that question i
definitely don't
one of your housemates is cheated in a
hogwarts design by using a soft spelling
quill
now he has come to the top of the class
in charms beating you
into second place professor flitwick is
suspicious of what happened he draws you
to one side after his last and asks you
whether or not your classmate is a
forbidden quill what do you do do you
tell him the truth
um if your classmate is prepared to win
by cheating he deserves to be found out
also as you're both in the same house
any points he
loses will be regained by you for coming
to his place okay
you would not wait to be asked to tell
if you knew that someone was using
a quill you would tell him before the
exam started lions say you don't know
but hope somebody else tells him the
truth
tell professor flitwick that he ought to
ask your classmate and resolve to tell
your
classmate that if he doesn't tell the
truth you will
wait so so it's either like you if he
asked you you either say like yeah he
cheated
the answer is well i would have just
told him he was cheated he was cheating
before he even asked
there's i'm curious to see what you'll
you'll choose because lie and say you
don't know
or um tell
the professor you should talk to the
classmate and tell the classmate if he
doesn't tell the truth you will
kaitlyn doesn't like confrontation but
she also likes things to be proper
and not out of order the thing is like
if your professor asked you
and then you said no then you are
then you're lying and you're like in on
the lie
and i feel like these are wizards like
they're gonna find out they're gonna
find out
so i wouldn't hide it i also i don't
think
i wouldn't like come to him to tell him
if i wasn't asked
like i'm not going to stir up trouble
but if i was
i was asked like the main two i'm torn
between are
telling the professor when asked or
talking to this or telling him to talk
to the student
but that almost seems more threatening
to be like you don't tell him i will so
i think i would just like if i was asked
i'd probably just say well
yeah i maybe saw something i think
all right back to me which of the
following would you most
like to study mer people
centaurs werewolves
vampires goblins trolls
ghosts that's it
i don't know not trolls not
really goblins vampires
be cool i mean they live forever right
and if
if they i don't know vampires are
interesting
werewolves you know
i don't know it's not as exciting not as
exciting as excited about we're
a little bit more out of control less or
no no no no they're in control
in this world right i don't remember
oh no we're back here kind of out of
control kind of when they turn
yeah right centaurs seem nice
but what would you like study what
sounds the most fun to study
mer people or vampires
vampires just like are cool because they
can live forever and like
what what would they know you know they
have i'm sure they have some cool
knowledge
and everything so vampires are cool but
like based on a personal
thing that i would like where people
probably have like a lot of underwater
breathing potions and stuff like that
and i like swimming and i like being
underwater
so it depends on how cool their
underwater village is
also like what's the act of studying
them like for more people do you get to
like be
underwater with like breathing
apparatuses or underwater potions to
like
live themselves probably probably
so it depends on how like well like how
well can i see underwater how murky is
that
probably murder people though i mean i'm
a scuba diver
i'm gonna do more people okay
okay sorry i just saw the next question
white or black or honest
what's that kind of question what the
heck the question is go ahead and answer
you're on it
i don't want to get ahead of you i'll
think about it i'll ponder the deep
mysteries of
two colors uh okay my question is what
are you most looking forward to learning
at hogwarts
magical creatures and how to befriend
slash care for them flying on a
broomstick
apparition and disapparition being able
to materialize and
dematerial lies secrets about the castle
transfiguration turning one object into
another hexes and jinxes
every area of magic i can
that's kind of a cop-out answer that is
kind of a cop-out answer i feel like
wouldn't everyone choose that kind of
maybe not hufflepuff
oh yeah um not hexes and jinxes
transfiguration could be
cool turning one object into another
thing
secrets at the castle is like i don't
know i feel like
it's interesting but it doesn't really
like get me anywhere in life
apparition and disapparition that seems
dangerous and scary
find a broomstick could be cool magical
creatures
i don't know i'm why are you even going
to hogwarts caitlyn
if you're not excited about any of it
well i mean i mean like i don't know
which time
i would be most excited about
i know magical creatures are kind of
cool yeah but
part of me also just wants to because
it's hard to choose so i don't
or should you do the everything yeah i
might do the everything because i'm
having a hard time choosing
the only one i yeah i'm just i'm gonna
do everything
cop out okay okay black or white
black cop out
okay i got one very similar heads or
tails
what heads
okay oh sorting how he's ready to make
his decision for buzzfest
i thought i thought maybe it was it was
giving us the questions in just a
different order
what the heck is this sorting hat
sorting hat
i don't think you know me yeah do you
really
also also this is weird because like we
are 16 minutes in
17 minutes and we also had like little
side stories
haven't other people taking this and
it's been like an hour full
yeah right what are we going to do after
this we'll have to figure it out
i have some ideas okay okay you go first
okay i'll switch it to your screen yeah
all right
you're a gryffindor courage bravery
i could see you as a gryffindor i think
like your guess was hufflepuff because
you're kind of silly
but i think you have more ambition
to balance the silliness how do you feel
about about gryffindor
you're like the main character house
yeah i don't know i always kind of
thought i was
more hufflepuff here you know what here
let's see what you're saying
oh hi dube you want to hang out little
one don't worry we chose black cat as
our familiar
okay mine is
ravenclaw okay so is my second guess wit
learning and wisdom are you just looking
up hufflepuff
yeah okay
let's read let's read your little
description okay
so for ravenclaw it says wit learning
wisdom
you probably know that some of
ravenclaw's most renowned members
include
gilderoy lockhart and luna lovegood but
did you know
the ravenclaw's great that this doesn't
tell me about
what i am that's just like here's some
people
here are some people unless emblem
our emblem is the eagle why is it not a
raven
well you know what
and here's some details about our
windows and
here is some information about the
stunning views from our house
what what so all we have are three words
though the only thing that describes
that describes like our personalities
and why we were chosen are like
three words i am wit learning and wisdom
which are
kind of ways to say the same thing i am
courage bravery and determination like
courage and bravery
are pretty dang similar learning and
wisdom uh
pretty dang similar you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna call bs on this quiz
i'm gonna call bs too uh like okay
hufflepuff is dedication patience and
loyalty
i think that that describes both of us
pretty well do you think we're both
hufflepuffs
i don't know those words describe us
well and you know
you you are learning and wisdom and
stuff too i think
but but about determination dedication i
mean that's what it took to make this
youtube channel happen
you know i put a i put a lightning bolt
scar on my head and everything
and i i was ready
to take this quiz and i have to say i
feel like you didn't really get to know
me
and i feel like it's results aren't
very descriptive so
how do you feel slytherin it's with a y
there you go okay pride ambition
cunning again that's the only like
words we get so i don't think that
either of us are really prideful
i thought slytherin was more like
ambitious
ambitious ambitious yeah i thought like
it was like ambitious and cutting
yeah so i think that you are more
ravenclaw than sylvarin
based on the three words yeah
i don't know i don't know i mean i guess
we both have some ambition too
because we do want to be like big
youtubers
yeah okay so
what's your backup caitlyn because we
we're
we're 20 minutes in my my backup plan
was uh
we play some obama llama actually do you
remember that game we haven't played it
in a really long time it's where there's
like rhymes it's not here i'll grab it
it's where there's like there's a rhyme
and you have to
guess any a figure from pop culture plus
another word for example obama and llama
and that's like the answer we played on
the podcast a long time ago
why don't you look at it and i'll all
entertain the podcast listeners with the
story
okay i'll be right back
also i'm probably just going to complain
a little bit
because
i mean so so the first online quiz that
we took
was the the personality test
and interestingly enough we took that
personality test because
one day i randomly stumbled across like
a description of my horoscope
and i'm like dang that horoscope's
actually kind of kind of accurate
that's weird so i was like no
personality has to be better i disagree
with the personality test
i took a sorting hat quiz
and i disagree with that too is
is the most accurate description of me
that i've gotten from random internet
sources
the the astrology sign
may be maybe we need to do like a little
mini episode on that where we like do a
reading of our
the astrology sign that i that i found
of myself because
that's crazy was that a good story
hi how was your time with the audience
audience how was your time with evan
that was good i kind of complained a
little bit
it's interesting i was telling them how
remember when we found the astrology
sign that described
me and it was pretty accurate and then
yours is pretty accurate
that seems more accurate than any other
stuff yeah of all the things that has
been the most accurate
weird weird okay do you remember how to
play this i only kind of remember
um i believe there are clues here let me
see
okay so basically we and you guys can
play along with us which is why this is
fun
um is on the card
don't do that one do this one it gives
you clues there are three sets of clues
that the
reader can choose from and then the
answer that the guest
has to guess is a pop culture figure
rhyme basically so
um so an example is rapper who sounds
like charlie brown's pet
is talking too much is taking up too
much space on the highway
snoopy is the rapper who sounds like
charlie brown's pet
oh you're close snoopy is charlie
brown's pet what's the rapper that
sounds like sneaky
dog yeah there's a roadhog yeah yeah
yeah
so you get to keep that one because i
win
you got it oh rudder so you guys can
play too so
we'll play for a little bit we have
another game in a while hey dube oh i'm
sorry dude
the card box is way too small do you
want to hop up
all right star of the matrix joins
alibaba's gang
um alibaba's gang
okay start with the first one so
keanu reeves so kiana can you read the
second part
joins alibaba's gang gang
or game
reeves keanu reeves
uh uh 40 thieves yeah yeah
keanu reeves is
okay i'm like sitting sideways because
jube like wants to hop up
i take half you wait i get this oh you
do i guessed it right
okay yeah
twerking singer writing on egyptian
paper what
what twerking statement this is the name
you would know the most
out of the three workings paper
twerking twerking singer writes on a
piece of
egypt i'm gonna give you a hint
parchment parchment
i'm gonna give you a hint about the
singer because there's a lot of twerking
singers yeah there's so
many they're out there they'll be
twerking yeah they all be twerking um
it's a parchment right no what egyptian
paper
egyptian paper not a scroll no can i
give you the other part because it might
it'll help a lot um i came in like a
wrecking ball
miley cyrus writes on a piece of papyrus
yes ah
i mean that was a big hint thank you
yeah
i kind of gave that one away ear biting
boxer is
cleaning with a british vacuum like
tyson uses a dyson
oh that's great that's a good one
okay ace ventura actor is very
her student and furry i don't know what
her stoop means pursuit
wait i'm completely lost do that again
don't worry about that word
ace ventura actor is very furry
jim carrey
carrey is harry yeah
that's not good would you
rather i chose okay
um carrie from sex in the city and joy
is the company
of the host of the price is right sarah
jessica
parker hangs out with bob barker yeah
that's pretty good that was pretty easy
i'm gonna start giving you harder ones
okay i'm gonna start giving you harder
ones
baywatch and knight rider actor forcing
air out of his mouth because he has a
cold
um sneezing
what do you sneeze well i mean that is
one way
okay um so i think man might be using
yeah he's like the
the dude he's like like the dude that
runs on the beach that
drives the car from rome he's david
hasselhoff
has a cough yeah
okay new star wars droid
is taking out her boyfriend bb-8 on a
date
yeah i didn't know that bb-8 was a girl
me neither or her boyfriend
yeah i didn't know bb it was a girl yeah
huh i'm trying to like think back to the
movie
all i remember is like the thumbs up
yeah i just remember the thumbs up yeah
that's right
that's it okay
all i want for christmas is you singer
is lactose intolerant
mariah carey doesn't like dairy yeah are
these too easy
i don't know here's we could take do the
harder version which is where it doesn't
give you a clue to read and you have to
make up the clue
are we ready for that okay okay let's
try it let's try it if we're not ready
for it we'll go back to our safety net
where is that one because it's right
here yeah so in this one
we were reading clues that match with
what we want them to say
okay you go because i did the last one i
don't
know any of these walter cronkite i
don't know who that is
you could just go grab a different card
i'll just grab okay okay okay all right
um uh the friend
of the seven dwarves um
uh has junk in the trunk
snow white got a big butt
i i messed up excuse me excuse me
the very first disney princess has junk
in the trunk
is it not snow white i said snow white
was was that the first one yeah the
second
disney princess has junk in the trunk
cinderella
is that not the right princess maybe you
should work
i'm not doing good at this um uh um oh i
know
what someone who like falls asleep
really easily
sleeping beauty got a booty
what's that called where you just like
fall asleep narcolepsy marquez
a narcoleptic princess house drunk in
the trunk
you did great on the jungle thank you
thank you okay
um oh yeah and you can't use any words
that are part of it um this is more fun
it's more challenging
but this is more fun yellow flying
cartoon character
um detects detects
poop the scent of poop
yellow flying cartoon character
yellow yellow avian cartoon character
tweety bird smells a turd
wow wow this is good okay
flying disney elephant
likes gumbo yes
that's the only thing that rhymes with
dumbo pretty much
all right go for it okay
the dark knight really likes the song
yummy batman
is a justin bieber fan what
what mental connection yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay
um uh rapper who likes mama spaghetti
is um is uh um
fixing um a uh
a piece of clothing eminem is sewing a
hem
thank you you're welcome okay
um oh
dude did you did you watch uh
sorry i'm gonna do i'm just gonna i just
wanna do the ones where i can do like
impressions
but it may not land actress who said
natalie is visiting
um the city where the eiffel tower is
located
paris natalie
from the movie house bunny
natalie she does it as a way to remember
names
oh yeah you're like hi i'm evan and you
just met me i'd be like evan
i remember that scene is she the same
person that does um
legally blonde no she's blonde
wow she
i think was married to um
andy from parks and rec in real life
no i don't know that trivia anna ferris
uh all right
do you want another one from this card
no i failed i failed i get in
so you are winning now caitlyn
okay so now i'm gonna have to trip you
up
but i'm just too good at describing
things i guess
so um uh
star wars hero rides
or no star wars hero um
is traveling in the desert on a
humped animal on a camel
mark camel rides a camel see that's
tricky because like i
happen to guess the actor's name but at
first i was thinking like
luke skywalker star wars hero yeah
okay um
arachnid superhero
likes plastic dolls spiderman
is a american doll fan
no uh likes plastic what dolls
dolls plastic dolls it's more common
doll
barbie yeah spider-man likes barb is a
barbie fan
that's not a good sentence because like
shouldn't the
like object be the end word that it
rhymes with
because yeah they've done the fan thing
twice because they had like
batman is a bieber fan yeah and that's
that's lame that's just like being lazy
rhyming
yeah right lazy rhyming
okay um a california girl
um goes to war
katy perry
goes to war
it's katy perry right yeah okay yeah
katy perry
it's a stretch joins the navy
like katy perry go through the other
services army joins the army nope joined
some marines
nope what
i stumped you katy perry you said it was
a stretch one too
yeah katie
perry
the coast guard she goes to war
is it not joins the blank it is joins
the blank
joins the military
almost thumped you on that one oh you
almost got me okay well i think that
that's that might be enough game
i don't know it's like i just wasn't in
the mental mind space to like
not do harry potter for this long you
wanted to do harry potter
longer i drew a lightning bolt in my
head and everything
i don't know i think that the main thing
is like i just i think i'm mainly
disappointed
because i feel like i was sorted before
it knew me
yeah you know what i mean yeah you know
i kind of feel the same i kind of feel
like for as many people want to know
what
house they're in this should this should
be better than a buzzfeed quiz
you know what i mean yeah i feel like it
was worse than a buzzfeed quiz
i feel like black or white yeah heads or
tails
yeah what's up with that like neither of
those
those are dumb those are just done and
i'm disappointed those are dumb
i feel like also they should have put
you in more like
circumstances that like told who you are
but at the same time
i also have to say since the end results
aren't fully described
you know like hufflepuff is just
dedication patience and loyalty and
raven clauses
wit learning and wisdom if there isn't
like a psychological profile that goes
along with them
if you're not like putting them in a
different if you're not putting them in
a house
for any reason that has to do with like
who they are
then then it's hard to ask questions to
really ascertain who they are
right but it should be putting you in
the house based on who you are
okay caitlin i have i have a game okay
i am going to come up with questions
that i think tell a lot about who you
are
okay i think that's an interesting game
okay first question
if um
uh you are in a store
and you um
knock over a display
case display rack and
it falls on the ground makes a big mess
and then the store owner walks around
the corner
and is like oh my gosh and they see
someone in the distance that's like
leaving in a hurry
they assume it's the other person and
they
are like oh my gosh that person they
should they
i can't believe they did this are you
gonna say
yeah i can't believe that they did that
or are you gonna say oh i'm sorry i'm
sorry that was me that was me i'll help
clean it up i would say it was me and i
would clean it up
but i also feel like most people would
not admit that they would let the other
person
i mean like i work no no but you you
have to like you have to really look
inside of yourself and answer
i worked in retail and i also like
straightening things
because like in that flash of like like
like embarrassment and stuff like that
it's like
really i think tempting for you to say
if someone has
already like taken the blame off of you
and it's not
on you i think that it'd be pretty
tempting for a lot of people to say
maybe i guess to me it's not i wouldn't
really feel like
that much embarrassment like personal
embarrassment i'd feel
bad because what if it was glass items
and they
broke and you'd have to pay for them
like it was like five
hundred dollars and you were the damages
you have to pay for them
you don't know you don't know i mean i
still feel like it would be the right
thing to
say it was you what if it was ten
thousand dollars
i should not be in that store
they shouldn't have display cases
exactly put that in a safe place that's
on you
you know that reminds me of um i heard
this on a podcast but it was like
um whether or not people put their
grocery carts back
in the designated grocery cart spot is a
good measure
of if they're a good member of society
or a bad member of society that's so
interesting
here here are the um here are the
reasons why
that particular thing really shows that
one there's no technical consequences
for not doing it
it's not like if you don't do it you're
gonna get a fine
so your only reason for doing it is
because like you should
it's also like no one's gonna recognize
you for it
yeah no one's gonna like call you out or
recognize you for it it's also
it's like not too inconvenient but not
too
convenient it's it's like you know if
it's too easy then it's kind of like
obvious but you do have to walk a little
bit but it's not
so hard that like you just wouldn't be
expected to do it
what does it say about me that i do it
90 percent
if if there's a designated return area
i'll do that
but if there isn't i just kind of push
it up to the front of the store
i think up to the lever the store is
okay
like absolutely different because if i'm
thinking like some sometimes like home
stores and stuff
there's not really like they just all
kind of float at the front of the store
there's not like an area but
up on the front like where you roll up
onto the sidewalk that's where a lot of
them
are yeah but like like is there a place
for them there is there is
like at lowe's like when i go to lowe's
sometimes i'll just like
push it up to the area but like part of
me
kind of assumes that like the next
person that's gonna walk by is just
gonna take the one that's sitting there
yeah well that's what we do we just take
the one that's sitting there that's
easier to take yeah but there is a pile
of them like i don't like
push it all the way in and tuck it in i
just kind of leave it
for the next person i think that's a
pretty accurate description of me
i think that tells a lot about that
this is fun this is this is something
our actions are better our questions are
better we should make a quiz
we should i don't know what like the end
result is but like
interesting questions that speak volumes
about
what type of person you are okay i think
that another big
thing oh yeah just real quick real quick
note
the uh podcast has been blessed by the
supervisor at this moment
because we we are
taking a new brave path for the podcast
we are improvising
we're totally improvising i kind of like
it
we didn't know the pottermore quiz would
be something
i kind of like it it's kind of exciting
yeah it kind of feels like we're on like
live stream
or something right i know especially now
that the supervisor is here blessing us
i'm almost at blessing the stream
is your tail she's like knocking the mic
with your tail hello she just like
buried her head in caitlyn's stomach
like yeah she likes to bury her head
this is like a thing that i always like
and i don't know this seems kind of mean
to say but like
i kind of like make inferences about
people based on how they judge
waiters and clerks and store people
and like people in the service industry
i definitely like
judge people if they're like i kind of
judge people a little bit because that's
something that you can see
so obviously and i think it does
yeah people are being mean to people in
the service industry
if people are being karen's i'm not even
sure if it's even karen's like
no it's not i said that like it's a joke
but there's lots of different there's
people who like
think that they're entitled to like
something i don't know
yeah but i think that that's like really
that's not something that that's not
really a question you can ask someone
that's more just something that you
observe
also some of those stuff like people
won't say like oh yeah i'm a jerk to
wait
so it's kind of like when you're
designing these questions you almost
need to like
trick people into saying they're bad
trick people into saying they're bad but
then like
also it kind of depends are you taking
the quiz to see
like get the result that you want or
what and also what kind of quiz is it
because if it's like what flavor of
cheesecake are you
doesn't really matter if you're a good
person or a bad person but is it like
are you a good person or a bad person
yeah i think i think the best question
in the pottermore quiz was the one i got
about like telling on the cheating
student yeah that introduced some
ethical concerns yeah and like
what type of person are you that was the
best question
in the pottermore quiz there should have
been more of that there were subtle
differences between the two
between the four another thing that they
could have done it's interesting
there's very little overlap between my
questions and your questions
maybe one thing that they could have
added in the the
the sorting hat online version is like
how intense do you want this quiz to be
yeah do you want the
20 minute quiz or do you want the hour
quiz yeah do you uh yeah how how
how intense do you want and then you can
choose do you want to express sorting
or they're like you know deep sorting
deep sorting and then you could because
like there was more questions to be had
that we just weren't served for a reason
an arbitrary reason
we there's like at least twice as many
questions yeah that is so
true they were cheating us out of
questions i wanted more questions
more questions well
i mean we weren't gonna do anything
really with the results i was just
curious because people have like guessed
in our videos before
yeah i'm pretty sure they guessed that
we were hufflepuffs well guys if there
is another
yes sorting quiz out there
let us know and maybe eventually we'll
have to find
some way to do uh like uh um
astrology oh zodiac zodiac
zodiac like little segment
because that's more accurate perhaps
more accurate evidently
yeah all right i guess it's time for
thing of the week
what's my thing of the week yours is oh
the pumpkin thing
oh yeah yeah yeah so as you guys have
maybe
seen in our main video we carved
pumpkins this week and then we covered
them
in resin and we we got this like pumpkin
gutter
i'm not sure when you'll ever use this
anytime you're carving pumpkins
once a year you're carving pumpkins it
worked great and it was fun to use and
it saved so much time
um you do have to know how to use it
kind of start up high rev it high
and you need a drill drill and stuff
like that so you probably can do it
wrong but
if you do it right it works really well
it was super fast it's like it's like
one of those specialty tools
that's so specialty but it works really
well yeah yeah i mean that's true how
often are you gonna be gutting pumpkins
maybe you can use it for other stuff
though
yeah like you can comparing other foods
yeah with your drill it's just like a
really intense whisk that also cuts
things yeah
you could carve out a watermelon juice
it
and then like put a straw in the middle
make like watermelons
smoothies yeah in the watermelon in the
watermelon what about the seeds
don't worry about that they get
pulverized
yeah they just drink the crunchy beds
all right caitlyn what's your thing of
the week
my thing of the week is a spooky game we
started playing this month called
phasmophobia which
if you um are involved with like the
online gaming community at all you've
probably heard of because a lot of
people have been playing it but it's
very fun
it's like a ghost hunting game um and it
kind of just dropped you right into it
it's still in the alpha or beta or
something but it's it's uh
it's pretty good i mean yeah well it's
cool because like it um
you basically select different houses to
go to to investigate the ghost
you have all your tools it's just like
ghost hunting shows where you have like
your
your um emf reader and
your little recorder and your cameras
and
all these various things to like detect
the ghosts
um but they can also get you and the
longer you're in the house the more
like likely it is that the ghosts are
gonna kill you
um but one of the coolest things to me
that i thought was like a very unique
thing for a game
is you hook up a microphone to your
computer and you can
talk to the ghosts and the ghosts are
always
listening they're always listening and
like if you say their name they will get
angry and sometimes
react and when you when you hide from
them you have to hide in the corner and
then be
quiet because they can hear you which
is crazy that's so cool and it's just
like i don't know it was very immersive
the audio aspect of it i thought can you
imagine that in vr
well you can play it in vr you can play
like when they come to kill you oh my
god they always wrap their hands around
your face and like
pull you in to this like
interdimensional
like soul trap area and it's like really
creepy
could you imagine if you're just trying
to hide there and then hands reach
around your face in vr
to pull you into the beyond or just like
being in vr and hiding yourself in a
cabinet
yeah you know but it's also cool there's
like um sometimes you'll find like a
ouija board
and you can ask questions on the ouija
board and get responses
like this is very cool cool it is in
an early stage um so like
there's just a few different types of
houses and then i'm i think things are
like sort of randomized i'm not
fully sure um my guess is eventually
they'll add
more layouts of houses and things like
that you can do but there's some
like interesting stuff there's like a
cabin and a giant school
and like normal houses and stuff it's
cool it'd be cool if they added like
more traps and more like unique things
per location
i think so that can happen like
different ways that like
ghosts can interact with the environment
you're at
that are unique depending on the
location yeah like i loved
the first time we found the ouija board
because it never told you about ouija
boards we just found one and we're like
do you think if we click on this or do
you think if we like ask a question oh
yeah cause we just asked a question
verbally verbally we just said like
is anyone there or like where are you
and then the ouija board started moving
it was so cool so yeah they started
doing more things like that
or like i don't know i'm sure there's a
lot of
paintings that sometimes follow you with
their eyes
oh another thing that's kind of cool i
do like how sometimes like
the room will look fine and then you'll
leave and you'll come back later and
like a chair is
like moved away from the table yeah or
like the cabinets the kitchen cabinets
are open when they weren't before and
stuff like that it was really
really good it's really cool it's a good
spooky game
so two halloween themed uh thing of the
weeks yeah all right guys
hope you're having a great week so far
thanks again for tuning in to the evan
and kalen podcast
if you haven't heard we're trying to
break prank the broader internet
public yes with our podcast so if you
could head over to wherever you can
review
podcasts leave us a positive rating we
want to get up in the charts
so people find us and they're confused
that's the prank good prank
it's a good prank hope you're having a
great day and we'll see you next time
bye
would you be like left out of my arms
right she knew it was the end
she knew she was like